si certains enseignants et élus de l'est
de la france appelle ça un confinement
local stricte d'autres réclament la
levée des restrictions sanitaires
illustration hier avec un rassemblement
de 300 personnes sous les fenêtres du
ministère de la santé à paris
manifestation organisée par le mouvement
les patriotes présidée par florian
philippot il est au micro de nicolas
coupé c'est extrêmement important là
c'est le 15e rassemblement qu'on fait en
même temps l'élan 15 villes en france
parce que on voit que la peur commence à
changer de camp on voit que ils font
plus qu ils veulent le pouvoir fait plus
ce qu'il veut on voit qu'ils arrivent
mois nous à nous vendre leur salade
l'assurent il faudra avoir peur les
variantes s'arrête vous annoncer
l'apocalypse ya trois semaines on était
aux bordures confinement on voit bien
que l'on l'a pas fait revient que ça ps
on voit que ça baisse dans les pays où
il n'ya pas de réflexion la fermeture
donc on est en train de le faire savoir
aux gens de plus en plus et donc plus on
fait pression plus la vérité et marges
héberge et donc plus on peut espérer que
l'on sorte de cette de ce cauchemar
c'est très clair moi j'suis malades vont
demander des miettes on a lancé une
pétition nationale c'est aussi des
patriotes pour tour ouvrir tout de suite
toutes nos libertés succi train du
masque obligatoire la vie on prévient on
comprend on traite donc on autorise les
traitements c'est comme les autres pays
qui traite on arrête de fermer dédié à
l'hôpital on enroule ou forme des
personnels soignants
voilà on fait tout ce qu'il faut faire
mais on arrête de détruire le pays
on arrête de fermer des métiers et on
arrête des terres nos libertés il faut
pas quémander quelques miettes ici et là
les musées ou je ne sais pas d'où il
faut trouver